in this video we're going to start
thinking about what it means for
something to be a multiple of a number
so we're asked which of the following
numbers is a multiple of 9 so pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's do it together and
one way to think about a multiple a
multiple is a number that you can get to
by multiplying the number in this case 9
by a whole number so we could figure out
the multiples of 9 by skip counting
that's one way to do it so you could go
from 9 and then you add 9 to that you
get to 18 you add 9 to that you go to 27
you add 9 to that you are going to get
to 36 you add 9 to that 45 add 9 to that
54 add 9 to that 63 add 9 to that you
get 72 add 9 to that you get to 81 and
we could keep going but to figure out
whether these are multiples you really
just have to say hey are any of these
numbers in this list now if one of these
numbers are larger than 81 we would have
to keep going to see it's included but
we can see that 46 sits between two
multiples of 9. 46
that sits closer to 45 but it sits in
there it sits between two multiples so
that's not going to be a multiple
another way to think about it is for
something to be a multiple if you divide
by 9 you're not going to get a remainder
but if you divided 46 by 9 you are going
to get a remainder you're not going to
be able to divide 9 into it evenly so i
am just going to
i'm going to take that one out of the
contention 77 is right over here it's
between 72 and 81 once again it's
between two multiples but not a multiple
39 is between 36 and 45 so not a
multiple between two multiples rule that
out and we can see very clearly that 18
is a multiple if i was doing this on on
my own i would just maybe be skip
counting in my head i'd be going nine
all right i don't see a nine eighteen oh
i see an 18. there there you go
especially if i'm only going to pick one
choice let's do another example
which of the following shows only
multiples of eight
so pause this video and think about that
all right well i could do it choice by
choice here so let's see this first one
is for a multiple of eight
well four
is can divide into eight we could say
that eight is a multiple of four but
four is not a multiple of eight what
whole number am i going to multiply
eight by to get to four so we can rule
this out and you can think about what's
what they're showing here these are
actually multiples of four not multiples
of eight we can skip count here 4 8 12
16 20 24 28 these are multiples of four
not multiples of eight some of the
multiples of four are also multiples of
eight
eight is a multiple of eight sixteen is
a multiple of 8 24 is a multiple of 8
but not all of the multiples of 4 are
multiples of 8 and i think you might be
seeing a little pattern here which ones
are multiples of 8. now what about this
choice right over here
16 is 8 times 2 24 is 8 times 3 32 is 8
times 4 40 is 8 times 5 in fact we could
skip count 8 then 16 24 32 40 then 48 56
so on and so forth but these are all
multiples of eight so i like this choice
and then over here 1 2 4 and 8.
well these are showing numbers that can
be divided into 8 without a remainder
you could think of them as factors of 8
you could say hey i can multiply 1 times
8 to get 8. i can multiply 2 times 4 to
get 8. but these are not multiples of 8.
what whole number can i multiply 8 by to
get 1 or to get 2 or to get 4. in
general your multiples of a number are
going to be are going to be that number
or larger than i was about to say that
number or multiples of it but i realized
i can't use multiples to define
multiples it would be that number or
larger numbers than it and it would have
to and if you were to skip count with
that number you would hit all of the
multiples